Now let me say you've done amazing work if you've made it this far.
You know everything there is to know about objects moving in a straight line. That is pretty cool.
Now you should go ahead and take a breather maybe go outside and drop some balls
off of leaning buildings or go to the forums and ask any of the questions you might have.
I said amazing questions, but really I should have said any because in the
world of questions every question is an amazing question.
There's plenty of people in the forums who would love to help you out and once you're done there,
you can come back and learn about two dimensional motion where you'll finally know
how to kick a soccer ball to get it past the goalkeeper, where to aim your arrow
so it hits the bulls eye and any other question that involves motion in two dimensions.